自己你都工作还没有搞定，
因为你还欠债，
因为你还要啥没啥，
所以你还找不到优秀的男人。
我今年是27岁，
学前教育本科毕业，
之前也在备考，
不是很顺利，
现在也不打算干幼师这个行业了，
我想转行，
目前是没有正式工作的，
有小额负债，
家庭普通，
上学花的家里面很多的钱，
压力很大，
就想尽快找工作。
我是高度近视，
可能会有遗传，
想在30~32岁左右结婚生育。
男朋友是我们认识了10年的高中同学，
我们老家都是特别近的那种，
他人是有上进，
也有规划，
对我有实质的付出。
他现在是在广东的新一线城市工作，
他的工作是需要出差的，
一年收入的话现在是12~16个左右，
我爸做金时他也是知道的，
他之前投资的话负债了，
还剩3万左右没还清，
我对他的印象很正直的一个人，
刚在一起没有多久的时候，
我就发现他手机里面跟朋友的聊天记录，
毕业这三年他的私生活特别的混乱，
具体的我就不讲了吧，
感觉很混乱，
不知道他是故意拿给我看还是试探我的底线，
我就有点难以接受，
我也让他去医院做了检查，
他也给提检，
报我微博，
我看了证明他身体是没问题的，
我一想到这些事情，
有时候我就反复提，
以前就会闹矛盾，
现在他确实就是也在做出改变，
手机公开诅咒报备，
他和那些朋友没有彻底断联，
但是也很少联系了，
我现在特别纠结，
因为他现在有改变，
我这个年龄也有生。
压力，
对我去他那边找工作也很上心，
如果我不去他那边，
尽可能的去其他城市，
机会更多一点，
可能有两条路，
目前一种就是亲戚可能会安排我去异地的私企，
或者是对异地的来务派遣的国企，
要么就是小概率的正式国企。
第二点就是去他的城市，
现在想的就是他那种黑历史几他到现在的改变，
我该不该就是翻天元旦他们实话说说娘，
我觉得他没有优秀到那种程度，
我要容忍他乱搞，
如果说他优秀到那种程度，
他可以给你买房，
可以给你买车，
一个月可以给你多少钱，
他挣钱能力很强，
有没有可能说容忍他乱，
在我没有钱的情况下有可能，
在我没有收入的情况下有可能，
但他没有优秀到那种程度，
明白吗？
我觉得你应该先走自己的路，
你的亲戚如果能给你找国企的话，
就先把国企的工作先拿到手再说，
男人多的是，
工作可不好找，
如果是异地的这种劳务派遣国企呢，
或者是安排的些私企呢，
还是先考虑，
就是亲戚这边嘛，
哪个工作好就去哪个，
哪个工作有前途就去哪个，
先找到好的有前途的工作，
还有可能找到好的有前途的男人，
他也就是普通通一个男的，
他也就是普普通通一点工资条件也没有好到那种程度。
对，
因为目前我先在干局债，
找到那种更优秀的可能会有点难，
那就是因为你自己的工作还没有搞定，
因为你还欠债，
因为你还要啥没啥，
所以你才找不到优秀的男人。
我先要成为那个工作很优秀，
不欠债，
我自己有经济。
条，
我先成为那样的人，
我才有可能有本事找好一点的男人，
虽然这个是之前的，
可能还是不可以原谅那种的嘛，
我觉得我说的已经够实在了，
我已经掏心掏肺跟你讲了，
姑娘，
他没有优秀到我要容忍他乱搞的程度，
凭什么要容忍这样一个平凡的普通的男人乱搞呢？
是就应该很现实的考虑这个问题，
他那么普通，
他还乱搞，
我凭什么要容忍他？
对你说的，
他就是真的很普通，
目前就是自己年龄，
也没什么工作，
所以可能就有点焦虑的那种，
家里面也很普通嘛，
没有考虑到我们两个家里的近，
顾虑的有点多了，
他现在有在改变这种东西，
所以很纠结这点，
姑娘，
今天这300块钱，
我一定要对得起这300块钱哦，
无论你是选择原谅他，
还是选择跟他分手，
请你一定把你的工作放在第一位，
你在哪里更有前途，
你在哪里工作挣钱更多，
你在哪里更有社会地位，
你就奔哪里去，
其他的先放在后面去，
好，
谢谢，
就这样，
拜拜，
我那个观点你们认真琢磨一下是不是这个道理？
就这男的这么普通还乱搞，
你还舍不得？
你想啥？
记得点赞关注哦。